thank you Mr Speaker as I regularly say
now I welcome the new Chancellor to his
place
both in four months of chaos and Fiasco
as this conservative government spirals
down the political plug hole but the
damage has been done
the crisis made in Downing Street for
ordinary working people are paying the
price
all that is left after these humiliating
u-turns a higher mortgages for working
people and higher bonuses for bankers
and they climbed down on energy support
begs the question yet again why won't
they extend the windfall tax on energy
producers to help footage the bill
yeah now it is good to finally see the
prime minister in her place
and not as the leader of the house had
to assure us earlier under a desk
but Mr Speaker what is she left with no
Authority no credibility no plan for
growth and it is clear to see the people
who cause the chaos cannot be the people
to fix the chaos they are out of ideas
out of touch and out of time
now the Prime Minister should have spoke
to the house today
but we know that she cannot do that with
a shred of credibility given that the
survival of this government now depends
on smashing to Smithereens everything
that she stands for and now she's
attempting to reverse everything that
she campaigned on it is not just
impossible it is absurd the prime
minister is barely in office and she is
certainly not in power
only five days ago the Prime Minister
said our prime minister's questions that
there would be and I quote absolutely no
public spending reductions but after
what we have heard from the chancellor
today every single public service is
again at risk from the conservatives
from our NHS nurses to our schools to
our servicemen and women with the
country paying the price for their
incompetence
the Prime Minister said that she had an
energy package for two years now that's
been withdrawn on the very day it is
supposed to be legislated for the Prime
Minister insisted that her conservative
mini budget would lead the country to
the promised land instead it has led to
the highest mortgages in 15 years and
emergency interventions by the bank of
England to protect pensions and then on
Friday the unedifying spectacle of the
chancellor being dragged back from the
IMF before he could do any more damage
to our economy
so she has turned to a new chancellor
who finished eighth out of eight in the
Tory leadership contest winning just 18
votes from MPS the Tories have run out
of credibility and now they are running
out of chancellors
the latest office holder has been in the
cabinets for nine of the last 12 years
at the center of a government
responsible for low growth and weakened
public services and him responsible for
helping run the NHS into the grounds
he was a big part of austerity season
one and now he says the Cure is
austerity season two and what Mr Speaker
was the Chancellor's Flagship policy in
his own short-lived leadership contest
to reduce corporation tax in a totally
unfunded manner not from 25 to 19 the
right honorable gentleman called for it
to be lowered to 15 with not a single
explanation of how it was to be paid for
the truth is had he won the contest and
implemented these policies we would be
in an even worse place than we are now
there is no mandate there is no
Authority for any of this
[Applause]
the conservatives have put a lasting
premium on people's mortgages uncosted
borrowing has sent interest rates
spiraling millions of people's mortgage
deals will be coming to an end in the
next three months leaving many families
forking out 500 pounds or more a month
will be paying a Tory mortgage premium
for years to come so how does the
chancellor think Ordinary People can
possibly afford any more of this
conservative government we've heard no
answers today now the chancellor has
said that growth requires confidence and
stability
I I agree but where does he think the
lack of confidence and the lack of
stability has come from it didn't come
from the sky Mr Speaker it came from the
mini budget three weeks ago
and what does it say about our country
that we are watching borrowing costs
hour by hour
it's not the sign of a strong G7 economy
it is the exact opposite
businesses are now saying that things
are so unstable that they are pausing
investment here in Britain the former
deputy governor of the bank of England
Charles Bean has outlined the
extraordinary damage that the
conservatives have done to our standing
in his words we've moved from looking
not too dissimilar from the U.S or
Germany to looking more like Italy and
Greece what a mess and where is the
office of budget responsibility forecast
has this government learned nothing does
the chancellor really expect the country
to take everything from him at face
value last week the business secretary
was busy undermining the office for
Budget responsibility today we have
received another massive fiscal
statement with no forecast what has this
government's got to hide they should
publish the numbers so that we know the
true state of the public finances after
40 days of this prime minister and after
12 years of conservative governments
now today the chancellor has scaled back
help with energy bills for families and
pensioners it begs the question yet
again why won't they bring in a proper
windfall tax on energy Bridges
and when will
come in full the government's estimates
of windfall profits of the energy Giants
over the next two years now no one was
talking about spending cuts until the
Tories crashed the economy with their
many budgets so I asked the chancellor
why should the British people pay the
economic price for the tourist mistakes
and what spending cuts does the
government plan to make
we believe that the government must
honor its commitments to Upright
benefits and pensions in line with
inflation will the chancellor make it
clear today that that is what he intends
to do
and what a contrast that cuts to
benefits are still on the table but the
one thing that Chancellor couldn't bring
himself to reverse today was lifting the
cap on Bankers bonuses why is this the
last policy standing in this disastrous
mini budget and let me come to
credibility does the chancellor accept
that once credibility and Trust have
been destroyed it cannot be simply
regained by a series of zigzagging
chaotic u-turns will he a prime minister
apologize for the costs and anxieties
laid on families can he admit once and
for all that the market turmoil we are
in was directly caused by the disastrous
decisions of his predecessor and of the
Prime Minister can he guarantee that the
bank of England won't have to intervene
again to save the government and what
guarantee can he give to people about
their pensions about their mortgages and
their household bills
the chancellor said today that
everything is now on the table
but is that really the case we know that
abolishing the non-dong tax status will
raise three billion pounds a year yet
there was no mention of that today how
can it be right that some of the richest
individuals in society allowed to buy
their way out of paying tax that should
be paid here in Britain this would not
be an eye-wateringly difficult decision
Mr Speaker so why doesn't the government
just do it
[Applause]
there is lasting damage which these
policy u-turns won't change
they've set fire to everything now they
insist it is all fine
the truth is Mr Speaker
an arsonist is still an arsonist even if
he runs back into a burning building
with a bucket of water because they
can't be trusted the Tories are Clinging
On for themselves regardless of the cost
to the country trickle-down economics
will always fail what drives forward our
economy are the talents and efforts of
millions of working people and thousands
of ordinary businesses the government's
economic credibility has been destroyed
they have harmed our Economic
Institutions people are paying higher
mortgages the same set of people doing
u-turns isn't going to fix it the only
way to change this is a real change in
governments
foreign
I Thank The Honorable lady for her
questions and I'm sorry that given the
speed at which things moved at the
weekend I haven't had time to sit down
with her one to one as would normally be
the practice before parliamentary
exchanges now I understand the role
opposition parties play I've stood at
that dispatch box myself but behind
behind behind the rhetoric and I was
listening very carefully I don't think
she disagreed with a single one of the
decisions that I announced to Parliament
and and that is important for the
country and markets to know and I think
there is also agreement on the process
of policy making I support the
independence of the bank of England
introduced by Gordon Brown and I know
she supports the independence of the obr
set up by George Osborne at the
government the whole government supports
the independence of those two important
institutions now I fully accept
and I don't think I could have been more
clear that we have had to change some
decisions made in the last few weeks but
what I reject what I reject
wholeheartedly is her broader narrative
about conservative economic management
let me remind her let me remind her that
the UK's unemployment rate
is the lowest since 1974.
[Applause]
[Music]
he reminds her that since 2010 our
growth rate has been the third highest
in the G7 she may not want to hear this
but these are the economic facts
our growth rate since this party came
into bad has been higher than Germany
France Italy and Japan and faster than
any G7 country this year looking to the
future we have the largest technology
sector in Europe more foreign direct
Investments than anywhere in Europe but
one country that is a legacy to be proud
of
now I was listening carefully for uh
some questions about the measures that I
announced but she didn't ask any and I
think she agreed with them
um
but but I will pick her up on one point
he talked she talked about the NHS
let me tell her
[Applause]
maybe they don't want to listen about
the NHS she talked about the NHS because
of the global financial crisis which
happened on her party's watch the NHS
went through one of its most difficult
periods ever and this party protected
the NHS budget
then in 2017 we were able to give it its
biggest single increase in funding
because of the difficult decisions that
we took and that party opposed
Mr Speaker uh in conclusion We inherited
the financial crisis we dealt with a
global pandemic we've led the world in
support of Ukraine possible because of
difficult decisions taken over the last
12 years each and every one opposed by
the party opposite so if she is
preaching today the need for fiscal
credibility which I warmly welcome
can I just tell her this the true test
will be in two weeks time to see whether
she supports public spending restraint
I've shown conservatives
shown conservatives can raise taxes will
she show labor are willing to restrain
spending
[Music]
[Applause]